- [Emily] But you also
had a lot of people
who wanted to speak with you.
- [Gary] Guys, I'm
so late, I'm sorry.
- [Stephanie] No, no, no
we're just standing bye.
- Bye.
- [Stephanie] I love you.
- [Gary] Bye.
- That was completely...
- [Emily] Was that's the
craziest it's ever been,
or was London crazier?
- Thank you guys!
Thank you!
- [Crowd Member]
We fucking love you!
- Thank you.
I would actually argue that
this was a little bit crazier.
All right guys.
- I am your number one fan!
- Thank you darling.
It felt different.
(trance music)
I agree mom the time stamps
make it seem much more serious.
DRock doesn't put
them in enough.
Yeah, he's sitting and
filming right now so
I'm making fun of him.
I always tell him that time
stamps matter because it makes
people understand how
ridiculous it really is.
Oh, crap I forgot about
a call I had mom, sorry.
I love you.
I gotta grab this.
Love you, bye.
Hey guys, sorry about that.
I got caught up with my mom.
Ugh. Dragging.
It's such a nice day though.
If it was raining right now,
I would be like,
"You know what,
I'm finished."
You can't trust him, you
got to go with something else.
Which are?
Discounted prices for
the next nine hours.
You know, something like that.
Have a good day everyone.
- Have a good one, Gary.
- Have a good one.
Then you're going to
get swept by the Mets.
Then that's going to be it.
- This meeting is about
us going through our list,
building the sub-list.
- [Gary] Yeah.
I clearly know
nothing about music at all.
Unless we get in Justin Bieber,
I won't know any of the work.
You'll tell me.
Love you.
- What are you doing tonight?
- What?
- [Gary] What are you doing tonight?
- Going out to Mets game.
- What about after?
Text me after if you're alive.
OK, let's go right away.
Bobby. Hey Rox.
Hey guys, how are you?
Good to see you.
- [Elevator] Floor 1.
Is this it?
- [DRock] Yeah, I think so.
- Hello.
- [Driver] Hello.
(hip hop music)
- Boy, did they freaking
make out on a nice day, huh?
- Yeah, I told you
I'd see you again.
- How are you?
Good to see you again.
- Good. How are you, man?
What's up?
- All well?
- Yeah, all well.
Can I get a selfie
with you real quick?
- Yeah, for sure.
How you been?
- Awesome.
Pretty good, pretty good.
All right, cool.
- Awesome, man.
Good to see you.
- Hey, keep up the hustle, man.
- Thank you. Thank you, brother.
- GaryVee, I need a
photo with you, man.
- You got it.
- How are you?
- I'm good. I'm good.
Oh, man.
I love you, man.
- Thank you, brother.
- I always will.
- I'm on a call.
Man, you're awesome.
You're awesome.
- Thank you, brother.
Thank you so much.
All right, at Propeller.
DRock's here.
About to go on
stage in half an hour.
- Gary, right?
- [Gary] Yes.
- Ricardo.
Nice to meet you, man.
- Nice to meet you.
Thank you, man.
- Very inspirational.
- Thank you, man.
Hey, man.
How are you?
- Do you mind if I
take a picture?
- Yeah, man, no worries.
- Awesome, man.
How are you?
- Good, man.
Nice to meet you.
- Nice to meet you.
- I've been following your
stuff for a very long time.
- So nice.
- [Man] Oh my god.
Can I get an autograph?
- How are you, brother?
Good to see you.
- Nice to see you.
- You well?
- I'm great.
- How are you?
- We love you.
- Can we get a picture?
- Thank you.
You got it.
- I read all your books.
I've been watching you
for years. I love you.
- Thank you so much.
- You're awesome.
- I'm a big fan.
Just wanted to say hi.
- Hey, man.
How are you?
- I sent you a Snapchat.
- Thank you, man.
What's your name?
- Anthony.
I'm working on a startup.
- Anthony, I need
to come out of here.
I just don't want to
be behind this gate.
- I just wanted to say hi.
- Thank you, man.
- A quick thank you.
Pleasure.
- Thank you, man.
Thank you.
Hi.
- (inaudible) we met
right after Crush It! and--
- Yes, how are you?
- I love you.
- Thank you.
- Oh my god.
- I'm so not used to
seeing you in person.
- Good to meet you.
- Nice to meet you.
- Could you sign my book?
- Sure.Tracy?
- Yes. T-R-A-C-Y.
Thank you for all
your motivation.
- Thank you.
- How's it going, man?
I wanted to say, man,
just thanks for everything
you showed me, man.
- Want a picture?
- Yeah, please, please.
I came up here without a pen.
- Anybody got a pen?
Thank you.
Tim?
- Tim, yes sir.
- Hey, Malcolm.
- Malcolm, how are you?
- I'm from Piscataway, Jersey.
- I love it.
- What up Jersey?
How are you?
- Good, good.
How you doing?
- Good, man.
- Just got into your content
maybe about four, five months
ago and I got to tell you,
all your stuff got me fired up.
- Thank you, brother.
- I'm a professional dancer
as well as a fitness instructor.
- Good for you.
- I'm getting ready to figure
out my brand and I know
I'm gonna take it with the
ground running and just--
- Just put out shit.
- Yeah.
- Don't over-think it.
Just start putting
out fitness, dancing.
There's no perfect system.
There's no perfect content.
Get it out and start, and
see what people react to,
your friends, the random
people that see it
- I'm starting to get my target
audience down and
I'm just ready to just--
- Don't even think about that.
Your target
audience is everybody.
- Yeah.
- Too many people
cripple themselves to start.
Anytime somebody comes
to me and says,
"I'm about to get my
content out."
This is when I jump in.
I'm like, "Do it right now." Go.
- Got it, appreciate it, man.
- Yeah, man.
Good luck to you.
- Can I get a picture?
- Yeah, of course.
- Cool, cool.
- How are you?
- My name is Dimitry.
- Dimitry, (speaking Russian).
- (speaking Russian).
- Good, man, how are you?
Awesome.
- Cool.
- Thanks, man.
Thanks for saying hello.
- Thanks for the inspiration.
- Yeah, man.
Good luck to you.
- Appreciate it.
- Yeah, real pleasure.
Thank you.
- Hi, I just wanted
to get a picture?
- Yeah.
- Can I get a picture?
- What's up, Gary?
- How are you?
- My name is Dennis.
I just want to
say you inspire me.
- Thank you.
- Everything you do.
Everything GaryVee,
with #AskGaryVee Show.
Everything you've done.
Great meeting you, man.
- Nice to meet you, man.
- Thank you so much.
- Awesome. Thanks, man.
- It was nice meeting you.
- Thank you.
- You're welcome.
- For everything that you do.
- All that you are.
- Thank you.
- For that reason, I was
able to be who I am.
- That makes me so happy.
Picture?
Awesome. Hey, man.
- Hey, man.
- Good to see you.
- Thanks a lot for everything.
- Yeah, of course.
- I just wanted to
shake your hand.
- Thank you, brother.
- Thank you.
- Thank you so much.
I've got to get ready,
I'm getting moved up. I'm sorry.
- Can I take one shot with you?
- Yeah.
- Thank you.
- Get your selfies set up if you
want to sneak it in because
I got to run.
- One.
- Thank you.
- Awesome, man.
Thank you, brother.
- Can I ask you one thing?
- Yes.
- First thing you do when
you wake up in the morning?
- Take a shit.
Okay, good.
- Awesome.
- Go tear it down, man.
- Yes?
- How does it feel to
be a celebrity now?
Do you feel the pressure?
You're no longer the wine guy,
entrepreneur guy,--
- Right.
- you're a brand.
- At some level I knew
it was gonna happen.
Sometimes you just know.
I'm unwavering.
All it does is
exposes who you are.
- Yeah.
- It doesn't change you.
- It doesn't, I know, trust me.
I've been there.
- It doesn't change you.
Bye guys, sorry.
- Nice to meet you again.
- I'll see you guys up there.
- Thank you.
- My biggest thing was I've been
at this hustle man, like you,
but I wasn't as
successful as you in '95.
- It's a culmination.
- This is ten
years in the making.
- You know what's crazy?
Actually, you can bring this up.
When did Facebook pages
started, seven years ago?
From seven years ago to three
weeks ago my Facebook fan page
number was 500,000.
In the last three
weeks, it's now at 720,000.
I had fifty percent growth
in three years after doing
everything right by everybody's
eyes for eight years.
- Yeah.
- It's just a grind.
- Yeah, man.
- It's non-stop.
- You never know when
it's going to be the event.
This could have been rained out.
- Oh dude.
- People pulled out.
Sometimes the sun just
decides to shine on you.
You know what I mean?
Seriously.
I'll tell you something
that's going to brain fuck you.
On the flip side, and I've been
here like twelve times already,
you feel like this is it.
- Yeah.
- This is my coming out party.
And then it's next Thursday--
- I know.
- And then you're
like wait a minute.
Why is not everybody
stopping taking selfies with me?
Where's my money?
Why am I not on Conan?
It's unbelievable.
- I know.
- Do you know what I mean?
- 100%.
- Right now, if I'm you,
that's what I'm feeling.
- Totally.
- This is it!
- I know. And tonight I'll be
like wait, where'd everybody go?
- No, tonight's
will be the best.
You recap it.
It's the best.
- But next week, right.
- Yeah, next week.
- I know.
- But this is an incredible,
ungodly start.
And I'm so happy that
it's in New Jersey.
- You could not imagine.
Super great day.
Big coming out party for Jersey.
Huge event.
How many people?
- We've got 7500 registered
attendees and we think we might
hit 10,000 by the
end of the day.
- Amazing.
- We were very specific.
Some people might think that
we chose you because
you have a huge following.
But we chose you
because you come from here.
And you represent this hustle.
- And have a huge following.
- [Stage Announcer] Make some
more noise for this (inaudible)
- Good job, man.
- Get it dude.
- Hi, How are you?
Good to see you.
(crowd cheering)
- How many people here
know the Gary Vaynerchuk?
(crowd cheers)
- Thank you.
Let's clap it up
for this fucking day.
How nice is this?
That's the real
star of the show.
Forget the panels.
The fucking sun came out.
Start figuring out how to make
money because if you're sitting
right now and you burn, and your
life depends on raising your
next round or your first round,
you're extremely vulnerable.
And I highly recommend
and I don't care how
bright the sun is shining
you better get real
fucking practical right now
'cause shit's coming down.
- What can people here
do today to help you out?
- Nothing.
And that makes me happier than
coming up with some bullshit--
- What can they do for
themselves, that you believe in
whole-heartedly, that
would make you feel good?
- Do something nice for somebody
else that brings them value
without having expectations with
something in return, which is
something most of you can't do.
- Ladies and Gentlemen,
Gary Vaynerchuk.
- Thank you guys.
- Great job.
- My pleasure.
- Thank you, Buddy.
- Thank you, Bud.
- I appreciate it.
Hope you liked it.
- [Stage Announcer] Once again,
make some noise for
GaryVee everybody.
- Thank you, man.
- Good job, Gar'.
- Thank you.
Let's go. Let's go.
- Little recap
halfway through the day.
What just happened, and I think
you should mash it up DRock
because that was insanity.
A lot of crazy stuff, much
love to everybody in Jersey.
- Fuck, how the fuck
are we going to do this?
Can we go in this?
Good.
Guys I'm so late, I'm sorry.
- [Stephanie] No, no, no
we're just saying bye.
Bye. I love you.
- [Gary] Thank you guys.
Thank you.
All right guys.
- [Woman] I'm your
number one fan!
- Thank you darling, thank you.
Reverse, yes.
Thank you guys.
- [Woman 3] Thank you so much.
Thank you for everything
that you do.
- [Gary] Thank you.
This is crazy.
(engine rumbling)
Dude, yes.
Stop for a second.
How you been man?
I ran into some
friends of yours.
- [Aaron] Got to get him out of here.
- All right man.
Good to see you man.
Stay well.
Propeller, you did a great job.
Super crazy Jersey love.
This man came through.
Had great time.
- [Man on Street] GaryVee!
- [Gary] That's the
hustle right there.
Yes sir.
That's the hustle right there.
That's the real hustle.
DRock, this is what I'm
talking about, not that.
This is the real hustle.
Nice to meet you, good luck.
- What's up man?
- Hey man, a pleasure.
Good luck.
How are you darling?
Good hustle, I love it.
Two things, one you have to
build an inner circle of four or
five people, that wouldn't leave
you for anything in the world.
- Right.
- That is the whole game.
Do you understand?
- Yeah.
- [Gary] I need to know you
a little more but after that,
and I could already
feel the vibe,
I'm thrilled to give you
connections.
- Awesome, thank you.
- Bye, bye.
- Nice talking to you.
- Thank you.
- GaryVee, three words to
give me inspiration
for any day I'm feeling down.
- Three words.
- You're gonna die.
Yeah, that's inspiration.
- Do something about it.
- I fucking love you.
- Love you too.
Take care.
Ready?
Life's getting weird.
- You know it's interesting
when you actually have the right
strategy and you put in the work
behind it, the results come.
We started getting serious about
YouTube, then I started getting,
I mean even as recently
as December started
getting serious about Snapchat,
and we got serious about
Instagram a year and change ago.
I'm sure you're going to edit
this with time stamps,
don't let my mom down.
(tape rewinding)
I agree mom, the time stamps
make it seem much more serious.
Lots of time stamps, honestly,
leave comments everybody,
I think a lot more
time stamps will help.
I know it probably screws up
your beautiful movie skills but
this is the DailyVee,
I want time stamps.
- [DRock] You got it,
for mom.
- For mom.
Yeah for my mom, not for me.
You know it's just
interesting what we just saw.
Stuff's interesting, that
wasn't happening a year ago.
Things have clearly changed
and it's because I've been
delivering the same message
but delivering it in the right mediums,
on the right platforms,
with the right contexts,
with the right consistency.
It's just meaningful and it's
having that right strategy,
mobile first world producing a
lot more video because
I'm great at video
and consistency, consistency.
Chopping it up,
subtitles first 5 seconds.
My Facebook has
exploded growing from
500 to 720,000 fans in a month.
Hitting new demos.
I'd like to say I predicted the
virality of that college, DRock.
(DRock humming)
I hedged?
- [DRock] I think you
did eventually.
- Let's be honest,
I think I did.
Everything's gotten to a completely
different place and that's what
happens for a lot of
people that do things right.
For a lot of you that are
watching that I've been jamming
with for a long time, some of
you out there with the 50,000,
100,000 following counts, who've
been grinding along with me.
I'm really talking to a specific
demo which is like
for all you social
media peeps who,
I was, if we're talking
branding, I was here and
you were here.
I think that same kind, if you
look at my last 18 months,
that consistency,
that contextual of content,
that investment in people.
I think it work
for a lot of you.
There's a real moment to this
transition of consumption that
the TVs now, Apple TV's and the
Netflixs and smartification TV's,
seeing you on the big screen,
always being with you.
That always consistent thing
that I never ever wavered from,
that engagement,
overlaying that content.
It's real, stuff's happening.
Stuff is happening.
Yep.
- Hey look who I found on the
street, GaryVee and DRock. Bam!
Then I'll, once you guys
have everything you need,
we'll schedule around you.
Here's one that I can tell
you that I can probably get.
Jess, I'm only thinking top 10 for
not what are gonna be
the 10 people we
eventually get, I'm making the
assumption that we need to drill
this first, you know?
- [Gary] Hey!
- [Woman] Hi.
- How you doing, man?
- [Desk Attendant] Good,
how are you doing, man?
- [Gary] Ah, damn it.
I really wish that worked.
Boys!
- Sir.
- Just talking about
that Super Bowl concept.
- Yeah, you should be
really embarrassed by yourself.
- That was probably the
worst calls of all time.
- In the Mets slack
channel yesterday, he was like,
"Harvey's going to
throw a no-hitter."
- I was like, no, take
it into the seventh.
- Harvey threw a
no-hitter last night?
- [Man] No.
- No, no.
He got rocked.
- No, Rami did a terrible
prediction. He got destroyed.
- Nine runs in two innings.
- Guys. What's the
matter with him?
What happened?
You think he's hurt.
- I, honestly I think last
season everyone was like,
no matter what, you just
gotta push for the playoffs.
You gotta keep pushing.
And his doctor was like,
"You are done pitching
for the year."
And he threw fifty more innings.
Now we're dealing with
the ramifications of it.
- Now I'm making
the worst call--
- I'm about to become
friends with (censored)
Keep you updated with it.
That's firm. Firm.
- If at the end of this I'm boys
with (censored) that's okay.
If at the end of I'm going to
dig up the ground, that's okay.
- At the end of what? Life?
- Yeah, whatever.
- This relationship?
- Whatever this is.
- Whatever we're doing.
- This elevator ride, definitely.
- That's what I
thought you meant.
Be with you in a second.
Yo.
- [Emily] Hey!
We beat you here.
- [Tyler] Fish bowl.
- [Gary] Why?
- [Emily] I took a train.
- We should do more
public transportation.
- [Emily] (laughter) But you
also had a lot of people who
wanted to speak with you.
- That was completely--
- That was--
Was that the craziest it's ever
been or was in London crazier?
- [DRock] No, London
was crazier.
- I would actually argue that
this was a little bit crazier.
It felt uncomfort...
It felt different.
We were in a weird
car driving away.
(laughter)
- [Emily] The
security guards were ...
- [India] In a car?
- Yeah.
- [India] In the middle?
- Yes.
- [Emily] Yes.
They just wanted--
- Yes. The answer is yes.
- [Emily] Yes.
- [India] Someone Snapchatted
me my apartment building.
Can I have a body guard?
- [Emily] Yeah. Yes.
- [Tyler] Fish bowl.
- [Gary] Get out of here.
- [Emily] It could be Gary.
- Really?
- [India] Yeah, and they
were like, "I live here too."
and I was like, fist-bumped him.
- [Emily] Ty is saying fish bowl.
- What's up, Alex?
Hello.
- Hi.
- How are you?
- Good to meet you.
- Nice to meet you.
I love the hug.
I love it.
How are you?
- [Woman] Good.
- How are you man?
It's a pleasure.
- It's a pleasure.
- This is really exciting.
I've been looking forward to it.
- Us too.
- Us more.
- Good. Well, thank you.
I'm flattered.
- Big fans, man.
- Thank you so much.
Thank you.
Tell me everything.
I want to get right in, you know.
- Okay, good.
- I appreciate you flying
out, and supporting my book.
I want to give you as
much value as I can.
Please just do me one favor?
If anything from this
meeting, be, know that I,
who I think you
all like very much,
it's a very, very, very
vulnerable model to a brand,
more than people think.
- [Man] Being a franchise?
- Absolutely.
It's a seductive model, because
it scales fast and the monies can
come in, but very quickly could
absolutely, if you're not very
careful and smart--
- In selecting people.
- If you are not very smart
about that, you have to
understand, one person in
Spain can really do damage.
- Somebody said something
interesting to me the other day.
He said, "Gary, what impresses
me about you is you understand
"something my mentor told me
which you can get there by going
"65 miles an hour."
Just promise me that all of you
understand you can get there by
going 65 miles an hour.
I'm thinking, how do I bring you
the most value and we're going
to do a lot more things,
I see there's a list,
I'll answer them all, I promise.
But that's important, I want to
make sure you feel that from me.
- Let me ask you a question, I
want to go back to how you said,
"Franchising is not
the correct model."
Do you think, but
you're not saying--
- Can you turn off the cameras?
- [DRock] Sure.
On a line's your mission,
one video gets posted,
turn 'em off again.
(laughter)
You start looking the other way,
one bad video, somebody goes in
with a camera, goes into the
clinic, here's bullshit,
this is what he's selling to us,
puts it on Facebook,
goes viral, 100 million,
it's all over.
- It's over.
- Quality control is
going to be key on this.
- Not key, it's oxygen.
Not key, not important,
not the first on the list,
the only thing.
I got to go.
Yes. Keep it going.
Let's roll.
(upbeat hip hop music)
How you doing?
- You're all over my
time feed on Facebook--
- [Gary] It's getting crazy.
- I feel like every single
time I'm like "I know him."
- You're like, "Gary, I know that guy."
- Yeah!
- [Tyler] Cody for five minutes.
Snapchat for Buckeyes for five,
- [Gary] Yep.
- Then Derrick the Greatest
is gonna come in.
- [Gary] Okay.
- You gotta leave in 35 minutes.
- How's it going?
- Cody
- I'm doing great man,
it's good to meet you.
- Good to meet you, sit.
- First time in New York man.
- No shit.
- Yeah.
- Good, nice to meet you, man.
- Appreciate it.
- Yeah man.
Perfect.
- Alright, Phil.
- Do you even work anymore?
I'm just keeping the
balls in the air that--
- That is the work.
My man, honestly, that is the
work, when people watch this
they're like, "You don't work."
I'm like, "Are you
a fucking idiot?
"This is the work.
"Keeping the balls in
the air is the work."
- Keeping the balls
in the air, yeah.
The problem is right that--
- You're orchestrating,
you're not playing
the fucking violin bro.
- Thanks, man.
- Yeah, man.
- Good to see you.
- [Phil] Have a good weekend.
- You too, Phil.
- You have to put it
into the hinge--
- Right there?
- Yeah, right there.
- Okay.
- And then--
- Wait, a little bit more.
- Okay.
- You got to get it in there.
- Then turn it like a doorknob.
Nice!
- Nice.
- Then, wait.
- [Woman] Gary's learning
how to shuck an oyster.
- Wait, wait, wait!
- What? What?
- I got to detach it from the muscle.
- Why? I don't want to.
- No, you got to.
- I use my teeth usually.
- [Man] Eat the whole shell right?
- Hey! Good to see you.
- Thank you so much.
That was delicious.
- We got two. We also
have a bunch of articles,
we have like 6 articles like--
- We need to find real time.
Thanks, brother.
- [Gary] See you later.
- Have a good weekend.
- [Gary] Thank you.
Hello.
- [Driver] You're Tyler, right?
- [Gary] Yep. How you doing?
- [Driver] Good, how are you?
- [Gary] Good. So, tell me,
what's up, man?
You know what
I want you to do?
- Yeah?
- I want you to make me five,
what we call, BSU's,
branded status updates.
That was my first
term for Vayner.
You know what I'm
doing on Instagram?
- Yeah.
- I want you to make me
five, and send them to me.
- Cool, done.
You're heading to
see your family?
- Yeah.
Little guy's got something
going on, so we'll go see him.
I have to walk into my
little guy's Tot Shabbat.
Oh, amazing, yeah, I'll
do it in a couple hours.
As soon as I get out.
It was an
interesting couple hours.
Did some family time stuff
with the kids and now back out.
Little bit of a preview of my
ambition for 2017,
coming home and
spending time with
the kids when I'm in New York
and going back out.
Just looking to hack more time
with them and at the same time,
balance my own wants and needs
and concerns about the fact that
I don't know if I can get the
momentum back onto the day,
but I think I can.
I was pretty excited about how
energized I am right now,
and so, it'll be interesting.
I'm really looking
forward to that chapter.
Much like the way
I affected my health.
I talk to myself, a year,
eighteen months, three months.
Every system is different, but
not system, ever kind of pillar,
that I want to make a change in,
is different, but I pound it.
I pound it.
I pound it, and then I do it.
Where there's
smoke, there's fire.
I'm creating smoke and now I'm
talking to you guys about it.
That's more smoke.
Really, really intrigued and
excited and felt pretty good.
It's a lot of coffees for
you on the Upper East Side.
You might have to start
carrying a laptop and edit.
Back to the grind.
(light music)
That was the greatest meeting
that men of business
have ever had.
The greatest, of business, men.
(light music)
10:01pm, Friday night.
Don't think most people are
going to their next meeting.
Most people say they want it,
but their actions
don't reflect it.
(light music)
My man.
- I cut off the
money part of it.
- [Gary] How are you brother?
Danny.
- How you doin', man?
I'm Brandon.
- [Gary] Good to see you, I remember.
Devin, real pleasure.
- You just got rid of
Scottie Pippen he ain't the guy,
but he could tell
this mother fucker.
- That's not true.
That's not business.
He got traded from Seattle.
He didn't do shit. He showed up.
He was like,
"Thank God, Mike's here".
- Yeah, but he also coulda
asked for another trade.
- [Gary] Get the
fuck out of here.
You're right about
everything but let's not--
- When he showed up,
Micheal wasn't the
best player in the world.
- Yes, he was.
Micheal wasn't the
best player of 1988?
Let's talk facts, guys, please.
Micheal was the best,
second best behind Magic?
I mean come on.
- Isiah, Larry, all them.
- There was never
a time in 1988--
- He might have been in
that Steph Curry, Westbrook--
(Maverick inaudible)
- This guy just said Isiah.
This guy rolled out with a
fucking Pabst Blue Ribbon
twelve pack.
(laughter)
Doesn't give a fuck.
That man doesn't give a fuck.
- There's real guys,
there's people who can
tell the difference,
everybody else is losers.
(light music)
- I'm on the DailyVee!
- Love you.
- I'll talk to you tomorrow.
All right, DRock.
- [Danny] DRock.
- Goodnight.
- [DRock] Have a good night.
- GaryVee, I love you.
- Danny.
- Benefit of being old.
- Good day.
See ya.
(light music)